you can outwork anybody how bad as they
are you do that you're gonna win thing
that people think about becoming great
about doing the extraordinary is that
it's just meant for some people and not
meant for others rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message out
work everyone over to you David Goggins
also if you want to know David Goggins
has to say about confidence and
excellence checking my 2:54 series where
every day for the next two hundred and
fifty four days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the links to join are in
the description below you will never
learn from people if we always tap-dance
around the truth everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today
[Music]
I got my work ethic from was the hours I
had to spend learning this when you sit
down and you're not smart you have a
disability yeah and you still want to be
at the top of your class I didn't want
to get by
what I realized that I can learn through
hard work and I can beat the
valedictorian in school but I got put in
ten hours more a day than he does you
know what kind of strength comes from
that when you're sitting down that guy
that that valetroy study for an hour and
you know I caught you I caught you and I
am dumb but I have the work ethic to
catch you that's where David Ganga's got
really invented yeah was at a kitchen
table with 20 spiral notebooks that were
empty and then three months later yeah
they were full and you can go through
that too I have me in my storage and you
go through these four notebooks of your
life and you're like this is how I
learned
this is unbelievable there's no miles
it's not about the models is
having a discipline every day they say
for me to learn this one math problem it
could take me ten hours and that's where
it you realize do hard work you can do
you can outwork anybody how bad as they
are but that's the part people don't
want to dive into yeah if you suck but
you work hard you can become one of the
greatest of all time
people give talent too much credit
talent is what you're born with skill is
what you can develop by working hard you
can become world-class at almost any
skill even if you have zero natural
talent for it because you're willing to
outwork everyone around you you can
quickly pass people who have way more
natural gifts in you who might even have
been in your industry for decades you
can pass them very quickly if you are
willing to outwork them so if you're
ready to stop blaming the lack of
natural talent for why you're not more
successful if you're ready to outwork
everyone in your industry then give me
an I'm ready in the comments below
pretty much my entire career has been
one of absolutely sucking having zero
natural talent and then just putting in
an insane amount of work to get great at
the skill I look at my youtube channel
as an example when I first started my
youtube channel I hated every video I
put up it took me three hundred and
fifty videos until I wasn't absolutely
embarrassed and I couldn't watch my
content back embarrassed full-out
embarrassed by what I made and seven
hundred something until I inspired
myself and watched it and thought wow
I'm getting decently good at this seven
hundred videos until I had a video that
I was kind of proud of when I joined my
agency I have an agent who represents me
who booked me on speaking gigs and book
deals and that kind of stuff and when I
first joined he said you're not good
enough I wanted to get in he said no
you're not good enough but he liked me
is that he like believe he liked the
message he's used to working people who
are more seasoned than me and so he said
you know what I'll take a flier on you
you kind of suck on camera he didn't
even say that nicely but I love your
message and I think you're a good guy
and I want to see you win so I'm gonna
take a flyer on you and then from that
moment I worked my face off to get
good at the agency and his first
assignment was do a foundation story
video tell me your story why should I
care and so I would record the story and
then send it to him and then at lunch
time he would give me feedback and I'd
record it again and send it to him and
at dinner time he gave me feedback and
I'd record it again and three times a
day I'd be recording the same video
taking his feedback and trying to get
better and this was a this was a long
video this was like 15 20 minute video
wasn't a quick 30 second intro took a
long time to do it and I must have done
that video 30 or 40 times before we
finally got one that I was able to
release that past the quality test after
a lot of work and I kept that up I kept
making three videos a day I kept
grinding them out I kept working hard on
it and within a couple months I became
the best practice at the agency I went
from being the worst the one who almost
didn't get in the one that had to take a
flier on because I was a nice guy and he
liked my message to being the one that
he said go look at what Evans doing you
want to model his success and it's not
because I was naturally gifted these
people had more natural gifts than me
but I passed them quickly because I was
doing three videos a day practicing
working hard on my craft or they were
having a hard time finding time to make
one video per week one video per week
and so if you are doing three things a
day if you're doing it three times a day
and your competition is doing it once a
week you will get better you can quickly
pass them and do the exact same journey
that I went through and it's it's not to
brag and it's not to say how great I am
I'm not I'm just a lesson in consistency
and follow-through I went from seven
thousand subscribers to 1.7 million in
five years because I did three videos a
day every day I am filming this video on
New Year's Day it's January 1st when I'm
filming this I don't know when it's
going out but it's Jan 1 as I'm filming
what are most people doing on Jan 1
other stuff I'm filming I'm making
twenty-something videos today my son
Hayden flew in on Christmas Day in the
evening and so Christmas Day was also a
Tuesday what was I doing I was filming
videos like if if it's important to you
you have to dedicate the time to get
better at it
and it doesn't mean you sacrifice
everything you can still spend time with
your family you can still have a life
you can still pursue whatever else is
meaningful to you outside of work but
whatever you want to get world-class at
you need to dedicate the time to doing
it I'm now attacking Instagram it's the
same thing again it's the same story
I went from 6000 subscribers and
followers at the beginning of 2018 to
ending it with 80,000 or 85,000 why
about halfway through the year I decided
to take it seriously and I started
posting six times a day
three videos a day three posts a day
three 225 stories a day going live every
day of the week like putting in the work
and that got good and I'm getting
results and people ask me are you buying
subscribers how are you getting people
to follow you are you using some
software no I'm putting in the work I'm
putting in the work and I'm getting
better and so you can apply this I am
NOT naturally gifted at any of this
stuff it's just by putting in the work
working hard or being willing to work
harder than anybody else in your
industry you do that you're gonna win so
I'm going to give you a three-step
process to follow that can help you
become world-class in your business step
number one decide what you want to be
world class act what is the skill that
you want to develop that even if you
have no natural talent what is the thing
and you decide and when you decide it
says I'm gonna focus on this thing I'm
putting my blinders on right those
things the horses have and put my
blinders on like this so I can stay
focused on this thing and by making a
decision you're cutting off other pass
I'm not gonna try to be great at
everything I'm not gonna try to do a
thousand different things at once
because then you're gonna suck at
everything for the people who try to be
on social media and every platform don't
do that you're gonna suck at all of them
pick one where you can focus where you
can be great at and start building
business from and then expand to the
other ones and so like what is the thing
what is the thing that you want to be
world-class and decide and in that
decision it also means you are stopping
other things that these are the things
that you're doing you don't care about
being world-class of those things so
you're gonna let those things drop
because you're focused on this path what
is that thing that you want to be
world-class at step two is model success
whenever you don't know what to do find
people who have done the thing that you
want to do and so Bill Gates saved my
company even though I've
ever met him because when I was
struggling my first business I thought I
tried everything and I and when I'm at
my breaking point I want to quit and I
told my business partner that I quit I'm
frustrating to say somebody must have
done this like who's sold software
before that I can learn from and I
looked at Bill Gates's story and within
a couple weeks a couple months I had my
first sale of thirteen and a half
thousand dollars and that was
life-changing money for me when I was
making three hundred bucks a month model
success when I started doing speaking I
looked at young Les Brown
I think young Les Brown is the greatest
speaker of all time I looked at him I
then worked with my agent who then
coached me and gave me advice so model
success find the person who is
world-class at what you want to be world
class act study their success see how
they got started learn from them compare
yourself to them not in a negative way
not in the eyes suck kind of way but in
a kick forward in a way that shows you
what's possible model success whenever
you don't know the answer to getting
better and step number three is practice
every day if you are not practicing
every day you're not gonna get better
you'll get slowly better but you'll
never be world-class if you want to be
world-class as something you need to
practice it every single day what is the
skill go back to step one what is a
skill that you want to be world-class at
if you are practicing it once a week you
will never become world-class it's just
not gonna happen you're not putting
enough work if you want to be a
world-class youtuber and do this you
have to practice speaking every single
day or you'll just never be great you
just never will you can be okay you can
maybe build a little business doing it
you can have some success but you will
never be world-class and that's what
this video is about I want you to decide
what you want to be world class at to
model success and find all the people
who have done it and learn from them to
get great and then three dedicate
yourself to practicing every single day
so that you can actually put in the time
to become world-class that's how you
work now I've got a really special bonus
tip that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know what is a skill that you are
deciding now to be world-class at let me
know put in the comments below
said I don't have talent so I just get
up earlier
the thing that people think about
becoming great about doing the
extraordinary is that it's just meant
for some people and not meant for others
and they spend their time making other
people extraordinary as a way to let
themselves off the hook because if
somebody has just gifted if they were
blessed by God they were touched by an
angel and they just have something that
you don't and something that you never
will have then it's fine for them to be
great and you to be ordinary but the
reality is it's not how it works
but somehow the cultural narrative has
become one where we celebrate natural
talent that if somebody is graced by God
that if they have something divine about
them that they're somehow better that
it's more beautiful than the scrappy
person who's had to work for everything
they've ever had
the guy who simply acknowledges like
Henry Rollins that he doesn't have more
talent than the next person he's simply
willing to outwork them he's willing to
set the alarm to get up to do whatever
it takes to find his path to create that
skill to outwork talent to show that by
putting in that energy and that effort
there's a magnification effect that is
far greater than anything that can be
given to you bestowed upon you you have
to grab it you have to take it you have
to have a level of intensity in your
life to be able to leverage it and
create something amazing and as Warren
Buffett said intensity is the price of
excellence if you want to be great
you've got to cultivate that intensity
you've got to understand it's not about
what you were born with it's not about
when given where you started or even
where you're going it is entirely about
what you plant at the center of your
soul how hard you're willing to go after
something how much focus you're willing
to put in your life and how often you
come back to that level of intensity for
who you want to be because if you want
to be excellent you will have to pay a
price and that price is eternal
vigilance vigilance over how you spend
your time vigilance over the demands you
make of yourself vigilance over what you
allow yourself to think and believe and
when you get to the point that you only
allow yourself to think and believe
things that move you towards your goals
that every day the actions you take are
things that are designed to get you
there and that you have the intensity to
follow that through to shape yourself to
create a new version of you capable of
doing something extraordinary then your
life is gonna be what you want but not
until then it's never gonna be anything
if you just make other people
extraordinary and say I could never do
that
the reality is you could and you're just
not so the thing you have to face right
now is that it is within your grasp you
just have to go after him
if you want more David Goggins check out
the top ten rules a video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
fill your hel disappointment discomfort
is a great learning tool